I reported Destiny to the police after
he admitted in DMs with me that he is
still holding on to sexually explicit
videos of an alleged minor. We'll watch
his video. I'll let this clip play.
We'll watch his video. He puts a lot of
value on on Destiny owning the child
born. He's a complete [__] [__]
These clips have existed for upwards of
a decade at this point. Willie is
obviously like getting an optics W,
right? He is undoubtedly in the right
here. Whereas in his previous video, uh
he was in the wrong. He literally lied
and smeared people. You won't address
the smear campaign that Destiny ran
using Willie as his [__] vessel. You
won't address Queen being smeared as a
doxer, as Auggie being smeared as
prodoxing, as all these people being
smeared as prodoxing. You'll never
address that. But the moment Willie does
something that you see is like a W or
good, uh you'll gladly make a massive uh
tweet thread about it, right?
[Music]
So Willie
tweets out, "I reported Destiny to the
police after he admitted in DMs with me
that he is still holding on to sexually
explicit videos of an alleged minor.
I've never been in this situation. I
cannot keep it private when someone
admits this sort of thing to me. I still
have the videos in the thumbnail. Very
epic thumbnail. Very epic thumbnail.
Full transparency, here are our DMs
right now.
We can go through and look at all these
DMs. I don't really care. I don't really
care. What I do care about is people
acting like
uh I say people, it's like [__] it's
Tommy C basically.
It's basically like Tommy C is the is
the person,
but I'm saying people broadly because I
know other people also share this
opinion. Uh people are acting like this
is somehow like a redemption for Willie,
right?
People are acting like this is somehow a
redemption and that Willie is somehow
for reporting destiny to the police
after, you know, admitting to whatever
child porn, whatever. That that somehow
this
removes all of the wrong that he did,
all of the lies that he spread, right?
removes all of the sweeping that he did
for Destiny.
Right.
Uh, and I say this, so Tommy C puts out
a tweet.
He replies to an Auggie tweet
referencing the the [__] and he says,
"Willie is clearly compromised here."
And obviously he's trying to Obviously,
he's trying to like do a sarcastic
comment, right? And I'm just going to
read out my own tweets because this is
literally just my take. This is
literally just my take, right?
The funny thing is, yes, he is. You
don't know what being compromised even
means. Willie knew this was absolutely a
possibility with Rose. Willie knew
Destiny's past with under 18s and
despite this, ran smear campaigns on his
behalf. You're a [__] idiot.
Genuinely a [__] Uh, and yes, this is
true. If Willie looked into this at all,
he has to admit either he he it's either
two options, right? One, he didn't look
into the leaks and then decided to make
a video on them. Uh, and he didn't read
all the leaks, or two, uh, he did read
all of the leaks and this one where Solo
says, "Anyway, she was underage while
sending you the vast majority of that
stuff."
Right? So Willie knew that this was
absolutely a possibility.
Willie knew that this was absolutely a
possibility.
So what is he doing here? I don't
[__] know. And then there's also this
like there is a a massive history.
There's obviously the 15-year-old dude
who's like, "She has fat tits. I want to
[__] her or whatever, but Destiny has a
vast history of of interacting with
under 18s sexually or thinking of them
or or verbalizing, I guess, thinking
about them sexually. Now, is this like
in of itself an issue?" Uh not to the
same extent as actually like going out
and victimizing a child, right?
obviously, but Willie acting uh blind
and deaf to this sort of issue
is really just bafflingly idiotic.
Willie acting like like I'm just finding
out for the first time that Destiny
finds people under the age of 18
sexually attractive. It's like okay,
come on.
And and also we we'll watch his video.
I'll let this clip play. We'll watch his
video. He puts a lot of value on on
Destiny owning the child porn, right?
The 17-year-old child porn.
And
the issue there is he doesn't seem to
make any moral condemnations. It's just
legal. It's just like this is illegal.
And it's like on the scale of like child
porn, 17 is like the least bad, right?
Obviously. So, it's like he's he's just
jumping ship. He's just like dishonestly
jumping ship,
right? That's all this is. He is
realizing that being on Destiny's side
is a losing battle and uh running with
Destiny's narratives to smear Quean, to
smear Auggie, to smear all of these
people uh is not going to work long
term. So, instead of, you know, coming
out and saying, "Hey, you know, I
apologize. I I [__] up. Uh he would
rather
uh just say like, "Lol, Destiny sent me
CP." And then [__] dip off because
he's a coward. Willie Maxo is a [__]
spineless coward. That's what he is.
I'll play this clip though.
>> Recoil like down here, right? And you
got
>> I'm scared. Hold on. He's going to say
to me
>> here, right? When you're um when you
first learn how to shoot, it's usually
better to shoot in the um isos stance,
right? Both arms are even. Your entire
body is like straight, right? your legs
are lined up with your shoulders and and
you're shooting right out in front of
you like this. But the way I didn't know
this until I started watching her shoot,
right? But um what happened was when she
when she fired, right, when she was
shooting like this and she shot, the way
that the recoil traveled through her
body would make her ass jiggle in the
most delicious [__] way. Oh my god.
It was the most beautiful [__] sight
I've ever seen. She shot the way that
her body absorbed the recoil. There was
like that as
>> So he's talking about a 16-year-old
here, right? And then there's obviously
another clip.
Take a girl to the gun range. Oh my
[__] god. Um I went with um I don't I
guess it's not like a secret anything.
You guys know that streamer girl Tori?
Basically, long story short is we went
to the shooting range and I figured out
there's literally nothing more beautiful
than [__] Oh my god. So, I had her
set up in the um I think it's called the
weaver stance, right? Because it's the
best way to learn when you're a new
shooter is where you is where you hold
out um you hold the gun directly in
front of you, right? A lot of this stuff
you see from the side. Actually, is the
side stance the weaver stance? Hold on.
I don't remember the names.
>> I mean, you get the point. He's just
going to basically repeat the same
thing. He's a complete [__] [__]
These clips have existed for upwards of
a decade at this point. Um,
but you know, Willy's going to claim in
his [__] shitty YouTube videos, "Oh,
there was never a pattern. There was
never a pattern." And it's like, "Bro,
you're you're like a [__] [__]
You're like genuinely a [__] idiot.
You are genuinely one of the most stupid
[__] people in the entire world. You
are just pathetically jumping ship now
that it's like convenient for you. You
will gladly use Destiny's narratives to
smear people you don't like, but then
when it's optically bad for you to stand
next to him, you'll jump ship. It's
[__] pathetic. It is genuinely [__]
uh [__] pathetic. Um Hellbent tweets
out, glad to see William Ao back on the
path towards rational thought. I don't I
disagree completely to be clear.
I disagree. This is not rational
thought. He's still a [__] idiot.
I'm expecting uh him to apologize for a
psychotic video attacking Queen, Jtock,
and Auggie RFC any day now. He won't. He
won't. He'll never do this.
Uh again, because it's convenient. He
will use Destiny's narratives. He will
use Destiny's tactics, whatever, to
smear someone he does not like when it
is convenient for him. But when it is
convenient for him to get an optics W
after his massive optics L, uh yeah,
he'll do that as well. And then Queman
obviously replies, "Maybe he should
address all those fuckups in his first
video, too." You know, when he uh
claimed that Tinder age verifies, which
it doesn't. I have a Tinder account and
I'm not age verified.
So,
I mean, I I I know firsthand I'm not age
verified on Tinder.
So, yeah. I mean,
does this really change anything? Not at
all, in my opinion.
Uh, and I basically reiterate my take
here, and I'll just read this out loud.
Willy reporting Destiny doesn't change
how this guy is a complete mark. And I
don't know if I buy him drawing the line
at Destiny owning CP of a 17-year-old.
This is the same guy who wanted to [__]
a 15-year-old and debated the ethics of
child porn with Lieutenant Corbus, who
was a minor at the time. The damage
Destiny did through Willie, the lie, the
smear campaign, etc. have already been
committed. Unless Willie does a full
retraction, this literally means nothing
outside of a virtue signal. This is
entirely optics, nothing more. Willie is
still a pathetic coward, and I agree
with this completely.
a dating app. Okay. Well, I'm not I'm
not saying if a dating app should or
shouldn't. I'm saying it doesn't. And
Willie said it did. So, Willie obviously
got a [__] up, right? Uh and then even
further, Nick,
he'll gladly talk about Willie in terms
of Willie getting like an optics W,
right? Where it's literally just like
cuz obviously, yeah, reporting someone
for owning CP is never going to be seen
as bad. That's obviously going to be
seen as good. And I'm not saying scene
as in like it's secretly bad. Like yeah,
that's good. Report him to the cops.
That's obviously better than just like
sitting on this or something or doing
nothing, right? Obviously, this is what
you should be doing in this situation.
I'm not going to like don't get it
twisted. Yeah, you should report him to
the police if he owns child porn of any
sort, right? Obviously. Uh, however, it
is so [__] pathetic how the only time
Nick Dioro will talk about this [__] is
when
Willie is obviously like getting an
optics W, right? He is undoubtedly in
the right here. Whereas in his previous
video, uh, he was in the wrong. He
literally lied and smeared people,
right?
So, this is just like insanely [__]
pathetic. insanely pathetic behavior to
only be willing to talk about when your
friend does something good and then
never address when they do like a major
a major mess up of a story.
This is just so like in incredibly
incredibly
just [__] pathetic. Any any nobody
should respect this guy genuinely.
Literally nobody should respect Nicholas
Dioro. This is
insanely [__] [__]
This is insanely [__] [__] Zero
people should respect this guy. When you
are only willing to talk about your
friend getting an optics W and you are
absolutely unable to be critical of
them, you are you are bafflingly
bafflingly [__] pathetic and
compromised yourself.
But, you know,
whatever, dude. Whatever.
Uh, is there any more?
Uh, and yet another shocking case of
self-sabotage. The omni liberal claimed
yesterday he has no evidence to give to
the police regarding Rose. Today, Willie
Max Show posted a video explicitly
detailing evidence that Destiny gave
him, including file names of per uh
purported Cam by Rose.
Destiny goes on to confess that he made
copies of not just his messages with
Rose, but all attachments.
Why would he be incapable of going to
the police with these files? True.
He says he's not sure if she was under
18 when the video was taken. The video
title he just commented on the date was
obviously before uh whatever the
birthday, right? Uh and as if this
couldn't get any more bizarre, Destiny
goes on to tell Willie that the reason
he is preserving the evidence is to help
a potential investigation. The exact
thing he told Eli was he wasn't able to
do. Incredible stuff, Stephen. Yeah, I
mean
again like Yeah, [__] Destiny's a
[__] Destiny's a [__] idiot.
Destiny is a liar, a manipulative piece
of [__] And Willie supported him until
it was convenient for him to drop off.
No, Godspeed. That's not even true
because he's not even addressing the
doxing shed. That's not even true. He's
not addressing the doxing shed.
He's addressing the new revelations with
uh with Destiny, which obviously this
looks good for Willie. Willie reported
someone for owning CP, for having CP on
their devices. This is obviously a good
thing to do, right? Uh so it speaks
volumes that the only time Nick is
willing to talk about this [__]
uh is when their friend gets an optics
W. I think this is insanely [__]
pathetic.
You won't address the smear campaign
that Destiny ran using Willie as his
[__] vessel. You won't address Queen
being smeared as a doxer, as Auggie
being smeared as prodoxing, as all these
people being smeared as prodoxing.
You'll never address that. But the
moment Willie does something that you
see as like a W or good, uh you'll
gladly make a massive uh tweet thread
about it, right?
and praise your friend.
Yeah. I mean, it was going to be a short
stream. I just wanted to talk about
this.
Uh, did we watch the video,
you guys? I'll probably just [__]
Isque Queen live. Queman's probably
going to watch it. Probably just send
you there. I only have like 40 viewers.
Augie's live.
Um
I might write into Auggie. If Queenman's
live, I'll go into him.
I got 20 minutes.
That is true. sick. You know, we might
as well just watch the video then.
Might as well just watch the video.
>> Earlier this week, we got to view
>> you went live for 30 minutes. Yeah. I
just wanted to talk about this cuz this
is like insanely [__] I'm not happy
with this uh behavior. I'm not happy
with this behavior. Obvious this is
going to be like an insanely short
stream. Obviously, I'm not happy with
this behavior. I think this is like
insanely pathetic behavior on
everybody's part, on Willy's part, on
Nick's part, on all these people's part.
Um,
this is like [__] [__] This is
literally all I wanted to talk about.
Nothing else interesting is happening
today. Uh, I saw that [__] King Cobra
died. I never cared about King Cobra.
Um, King Cobra's like a [__] who was
like literally [__] poisoning
themselves and everybody's acting like
shocked and sad that they died. uh even
though they supported the content
machine that is King Cobra slowly
killing themselves uh with bootleg
alcohol uh and then door dashed alcohol.
So I looked at that story and I'm like,
"Okay, are you people really sad that
this guy's [__] dead? You you
supported the machine that killed this
guy.
You supported the machine that fed this
guy uh poisoned liquor and you're acting
sad that he's dead. You pulled out the
gun. You pointed it at his head. You
pulled the trigger. And now you're
weeping at his funeral. It's like,
"Okay, what are we doing here?" Yes,
King Cobra the LOL Co. The [__] fat
[__] that made bootleg alcohol uh and
didn't do it properly,
so he [__] slowly was killing
himself. And then people would door dash
him copious amounts of alcohol. He had
him to drink on like camera and [__]
And then people are acting uh sad that
he's gone even though they, you know,
kind of led to it. So I looked at that
story and I'm just like, "No, this is
complete [__] retardation. It's just
a bunch of people virtue signaling." No,
our favorite LOL cow's dead. Our
favorite LOL cow's dead. Even though we
perpetuated a system that killed him.
No, no, no.
I And I looked at that, dude. It's just
like you're [__]
ridiculously [__]
You're like ridiculously [__]
I mean, if you're if you're genuinely
sad the guy's dead, I'm not going to
take that away from you or whatever. Um,
but like bro, I I don't know. How could
we have not seen this coming? How could
we have not seen this coming? What the
hell? What the hell?
But, you know, whatever. All right,
let's watch the video.
>> I reported Destiny to the police. This
is not clickbait and entirely has to do
with the DMs he sent me. A few days ago,
a Reddit post showed that the girl
Destiny shared Pixie's new
>> Also, I watched this. I pre-watched
pre-watched pre-watched. I watched this.
This is just a repost of the [__]
Kiwi Farms thread.
I'm not going to act I'm not going to
act like uh like this came from anywhere
other than Kiwi Farms
because I think I think that's [__]
This is This is like he'll he'll like,
bro, he'll gladly [__] on Kiwi Farms
when it's convenient for him, but then
he's like he's like a meek little piece
of [__] He's like a meek little
insecure piece of [__] He's like, "I I
can't talk about Kiwi Farms now. I can't
talk about Kiwi Farms now." So he'll
wait until someone [__] reposts the
same [__] on like Reddit.
It's so [__] It's so [__] It's
so [__] [__] Kiwi Farms is evil
until it has something I want to make a
video about. Kiwi Farms is [__] evil.
Kiwi Farms is evil doxing until the
docks is something that I want to make a
video about, you know?
It's like, okay, you're you're [__]
[__] No, you you can't say Kiwi
Farms now. Uh because you put yourself
in a situation uh where you're
explicitly anti- Kiwi Farms because
you're a [__] idiot and you wanted to
run a smear campaign on Queman because
you're a [__] [__]
>> Nudes with seemingly confirmed to be 17
years old due to her getting doxed.
There is almost a 0% chance that she was
not 17 during that time. So, I do what I
usually do and reached out to get a
comment. He said the girl Rose told him
she was 19 and in college at the time
and that the leaker Solo, who is her
ex-boyfriend, confirmed that she lied
about her age to him. This is true. In
similar scandals, this is where people
usually argue, is he lying?
>> Okay, what is this?
>> She lied about her age to him. This is
true. In similar scandals, this is where
people usually argue, is he lying? Did
he actually know the age? Is it his
fault if he was catfished? I usually
wait for all the details to come out
before I comment. This is not why I went
to the police. It's because he continued
to write, "I didn't know this until way
later, but the video she recorded with
other guys. The file names are like
screen recording blah blah blah." And
then he shows me a screenshot of the top
of a video clip and says, "Her boyfriend
was recording these on Skype calls."
That's absolutely insane to think about
him doing all of this if she was 17.
Well, this is insane to me because he's
saying Rose's boyfriend recorded CP
while sending me a screenshot of the
alleged CP. So I
>> what? No. No.
>> Asked to confirm if he just did that. If
you were sending me this, I'm guessing
you still have that video. Destiny
replies. Depends on why you're asking,
but yes, I created copies of all of our
messages and everything when that court
case started. Just to be clear, he's
admitting to having alleged CP
downloaded on his computer. He literally
has the video open.
>> To be clear, to be clear, I want to make
it abundantly clear, okay? I'm critical
of Willie Mack. However, however, okay,
however, um
I'm not going to act like this is this
is somehow like bad. Like, no, this is
perfectly fine to do.
This is what you should do. Yes, I it is
good that Willie reported this to the
police. It is good that this is
happening. It is good that this is
happening.
Okay,
this is good. This is perfectly fine.
I'm going to be critical of this and
critical of his behavior around this and
how he's portraying this story and
whatever. How I will say just to be
perfectly clear, okay, this is good that
Willie is reporting this. I don't care
that he's reporting this. My my critique
ultimately is not but Willie
whatever. Okay, this is fine. This is
good that he did this. I just want to
make that clear because I am being
explicitly anti-Willy in this stream.
However, I want to make it just
abundantly clear so there's no
miscommunication. Yeah, this is good to
do. This is fine. My issue is not with
him reporting it. It's his actions
around the reporting it that I have an
issue with. I'm talking to him. I go,
bro, there's been allegations at least
since my last video that she was
underage and you still have potential CP
of her. He replies, I have an obligation
to preserve relevant evidence, etc. So,
I created backups of all of the
important/relevant conversations. He
continues, I don't think I'm allowed to
delete it, lol. I don't know if it
counts as hiding/destroying evidence.
And I replied, "Talk to a lawyer. That
seems crazy to me." "Who keeps this sort
of stuff on their computer without 100%
knowing if they're supposed to or not?
Isn't that something you want to
confirm?" I continued, "You just let me
know you have CP videos saved to your
computer. You knew it was alleged that
she was underage. You still have them.
Do you see how this is? So now I've
confirmed that this guy has child porn
on his computer. Am I
>> Now I've confirmed that he is child
porn. W.
>> In 8 years of reaching out to people
over allegations, I've never had anyone
admit that to me. The last message he
sent me was one. I don't even know 100%
of her age was legitimately less than 18
when these were taken. So basically,
he's not 100% sure if he
>> Also, this is just like a poor [__]
video from Willie cuz the Jtock tweet,
if you look at the file name, it's a
date. And you can see it just takes
simple math. If you want to f You've
already mentioned her docs, so you've
already crossed the road. You're willing
to talk about this girl's docs, which
you know is ironic given the video that
you've just [__] made, you [__]
But whatever. You're already willing to
talk about your this girl's docs. You
know the file name is a date and you
know her birthday because that was the
crux of the docs, right? So, you could
have done the [__] math and realized
yes, she would have been under 18.
But you didn't because you just wanted
to get the [__] video out quick. This
is a complete and utter
This is a complete and utter just like
virtue signal. That's all this is. It's
so [__] [__]
>> He has child porn on his computer. He's
just 99% sure. Got it. Two. I'm pretty
sure I have an obligation to preserve
stuff related to my court case. I've
talked about it with my lawyer already,
specifically with regards to the Rose
stuff. So, he went from I don't know if
I could delete this to my lawyer says
it's totally fine to keep. I don't know
the law, but the idea that his lawyer
would tell him to hold on to CP for a
civil case just doesn't seem likely to
me. I don't know. Law Tube can figure
that out. Three, if something were to
come out of this, I don't know if I'd
want to wipe everything and not have
something to turn over to the
authorities. If hypothetically, whenever
a political creator is about to give a
hypothetical, you know you're about to
hear some weird [__] If hypothetically
>> her boyfriend or whatever was actually
trafficking her or getting her to [__]
other dudes on video for him. And if
there was ever some kind of
investigation into that, am I hurting
the chance of looking into him by
deleting all of this stuff? Oh, so now
the reason he's keeping the CP is
because of a hypothetical criminal case
that he is not pursuing at all. Okay.
Maybe these reasons are legally sound
advice that came from his lawyer. Maybe
he's lying and just saying anything to
make it sound better to me. I don't
know. I'm not a lawyer. I just know this
guy's admitting to having CP in my DMs.
60 GB according to him. Seriously, how
does he know the amount if he doesn't
have it? Also, how does her boyfriend
being in the wrong somehow make Destiny
in the right? It makes no sense. For all
he knows, her boyfriend could have been
17 as well. Dude, you were 33. I
reported this to the police and recorded
my interactions and calls with the
detective.
>> William, how you doing?
>> Thank god he recorded it. Thank god he
recorded it so we could put it on a
YouTube video. Totally not a virtue
signal. Totally not. Okay.
>> Hello. Nice to uh speak with you again.
>> Question
>> with his clean shirt, his freshly washed
hair, his prepared camera setup. W
>> copies of the
>> Yes.
>> when you guys spoke about having all
that.
>> Yep.
>> I also sent him my DMs with Destiny. I
don't know if anything will come from
this. don't like leaking DMs as me
respecting what creators want on and off
the record allows me to talk to all
sides of the situation, builds trust
with the creator, and also allows me to
get follow-up statements for when the
drama develops. But when you tell me
that you're in possession of and going
to remain in possession of CP, that
confidentiality is over. I shouldn't
even need to say that. If Destiny ends
up being legally in the right to keep
it, then fair enough. If he ends up
getting charged, then I'm glad I did
something. I'm just trying to do the
right thing in a situation I've never
been in before.
>> Maybe I'm nitpicking. I don't think I'm
nitpicking at this point. I I don't
think I'm nitpicking at this point. Um
I don't think he ever said what Destiny
did is wrong here. He's he's playing a
very very very smart game by just going
with legality rather than trying to
explain how Destiny is in the wrong
here. Um,
given everything else he's said about
Destiny, giving all given all of the
sweeping he's done, the subtle sweeping,
the smear campaigns he's run on
Destiny's behalf, given everything, uh,
I can't confidently say, uh, that there
is not some of that being, you know,
left over in this video where Willie is
refusing to say what Destiny did here is
wrong. He is not saying that. He's
saying, oh, he owns CP, he has CP, so
I'm reporting it.
He's not going ahead and saying, "Oh,
Destiny is, you know, in the wrong for
this. Destiny is a is a whatever like
bad person, whatever you want to say."
He's not saying that. He's he's playing
a very safe game. Um,
which in my opinion, you know, and
again, I could be being I I could be
being, you know, way too critical of
Willie here. Uh,
but it it seems almost like plausible
deniability.
right?
Like he still wants to remain close to
DGG. I don't know. It's just [__]
[__] Uh
it's just a total virtue signal. That's
all this is. It's a total virtue signal.
Total and complete virtue signal.
instead of like, you know, retracting
the lies, the smears, the [__]
correcting the mistakes of videos,
whatever,
he'll just make this and he'll probably
try to move on from it.
And then people like Nick Dioro, who are
praising him for this, are the people
who are letting him get away with lying
on YouTube about other creators and
smearing them on Destiny's behalf by not
being critical and then only praising
the good [__] It's just complete
pathetic spineless behavior from all of
these people.
If you only praise the good and you
never criticize the bad, you are giving
implicit support for the bad. Nick Dioro
and I I said I think I have I literally
have a tweet saying this.
Yeah, right here.
Nicholas Dioro after promising to watch
the new Willie Mack video on stream
takes this back and begins blocking
people like Quan who are accused of
hosting doxing communities in said
video. These are false claims and this
seems to be implicit support for
misinformation. And yes, I agree with
this completely. By the way, how how is
there any other perception for this
behavior? How are you going to have any
other take than Nick is implicitly
supporting misinformation when he
refuses to criticize his friend who is
spreading misinformation
and then when you only praise the good
[__]
Like obviously this this comes off as
nothing other than just implicit support
for this type of behavior.
But yeah, again, just to repeat all my
points, uh, you know, Willie acting like
this is somehow [__] new and that
Destiny has never interacted with
someone under the age of 18
inappropriately before is just
completely and and utterly false.
The fact that Nick or the fact that,
sorry, did I say Nick? I meant Willie. I
to be clear, I meant Willie. If I said
Nick, I apologize. Uh, the fact that
Willie is going to act like this is
somehow just like brand new and was
never ever a possibility before is
[__] ridiculous. That is completely
and utterly [__] ridiculous. You
either didn't do the research, didn't
look into it, or you did look into it,
and you ignored this. So, acting as if
this was never a possibility, uh, is
[__] delusional.
I know there's clips Destiny's like
streaming right now, I believe. I know
there's clips from the stream about the
Willie [__]
I don't think I'll watch any.
>> Doesn't really matter about the $10,000.
I think it's like right here, right?
>> I saw this, but I couldn't tell if this
was [__] a million times. Um,
I can do that and that's easy enough for
me to do, but when the people are all
coordinating in like little Discords and
keep trying to, you know, like [__] with
other people, whether it's Willie or
Connor or anything else, um, there's
nothing
like at some point. Yeah.
>> Okay. [__] W doxing talk. W lying
about doxing. W
based based based. Yeah. I don't know.
Again, pretty short stream. I just uh I
wanted to talk about this. There's
nothing else to talk about. Probably
going to end pretty soon. I I wanted to
talk about this because obviously I I
think this is just like complete
spineless behavior.
He's absolutely jumping ship. This is
spineless, wretched, pathetic behavior.
Disgusting behavior.
Uh,
and to be clear, I don't think you
should be criticized for reporting CP.
That's not I need to choose my words
very carefully because obviously I'm
criticizing Willie when he has done
something that is objectively good,
right? I just think the circumstances
around it are what makes it a bit
shitty.
No, he has never posted a retraction or
a fix.
I think the one time he's done it, he's
uh said in the title,
it was something to do with [__]
Mr. Beast.
Oh yeah, redacted.
>> Mr. Beast is
>> redacted. Update a new video. Fixing
misinformation archived. So, he could
definitely do something like this. He
could definitely do something like this,
but he won't.
But he won't.
He's done [__] like this before where he
where he will, you know, explicitly say,
"Hey, I [__] up. Don't watch this
video. This is just an archive. Go watch
this new video with fixed information."
You know,
so he's capable of doing this, but he
won't. He won't.
All right. Okay. Is Quan [__] live
yet?
No. All right. Well, he'll be live like
any minute. I'm just going to raid into
Auggie. I'm There's literally nothing
else I want to talk about. I do not give
a [__] about the King Cobra [__] Um
I don't really give a [__] about any of
that [__]
Uh I don't know when I'll be live next.
There was a good little a good little
rush of content the past week, but it's
kind of slowed down. So, don't expect uh
a lot of lives
unless something cool happens. Unless
something cool happens.
He died. That's it. That's the segment.
Well, my my take on it is way more uh
way more moral [__] because I think
everybody complaining about it is a
[__] [__] because by watching and
supporting that content and providing
him with alcohol and providing him with
a reason to continue making his bootleg
poisoned liquor, um I say I think liquor
is a specific type of alcohol. You know
what I mean? Uh they were basically
killing him. So, I think anybody who's
pretending this guy's uh or anybody
who's saying they're sad that this guy's
dad is [__] lying, basically. I mean,
sure, there's probably like your one or
two that's genuinely upset, but
you bought this guy alcohol. You
encouraged him to keep making poison and
feeding poison into his body. Um,
I don't buy that you're sad by his
death. I don't buy that you're upset by
this. Uh, this is the ultimate like I
don't know. I don't know. I just don't
care. Like, you're [__] [__] You
You did this. The viewers of this
content did this.
How much to critique one of his me
videos, dude. The critique is literally
he doesn't sanitize. He uses sugar like
[__] he puts like M&M's and [__] in
it.
Like just he's [__] I don't know.
What is there to critique? He's like, he
doesn't sanitize the [__] and he doesn't
make it properly. That's like how much?
I don't know. Like 50 bucks. I don't
want to watch that. It It grosses me
out. I do really bad with like uh with
food horror.
Like res what what is it? Resident Evil
7.
I do really bad with like Resident Evil
Like [__] like that really disgusts me
and grosses me out. I It's very hard to
watch and look at. Like there what what
was it? There was this one video where
he um
there's this one video where he
like has a burrito. He like makes this
weird burrito thing and then there's
like roaches inside the burrito and he
takes a bite and like he takes a bite
where there's a roach in the burrito and
it's like bro what the [__]
Like no I can't do it. I can't do it.
I can't do it man.
I can't do it. My bad. My bad. My bad.
All right, I'm going to end. Uh, I just
wanted to talk about this because this
is upsetting. This is like completely
and utterly This is genuinely like
maddening. This is genuinely infuriating
to see [__] like this.
Genuinely maddening. All right, I think
Quimman just went live. I I'll rate into
him. I know I only have like 50 viewers,
but Auggie is also live. Uh, go watch
Auggie if you want to.
Uh, I don't know when I'll be live next.
I'm going to try to get this video out.
I will I will show this. I will show
this.
I I'm like [__]
I want to do uh something in Blender for
the video. Uh because I think it'd be
funny because people were saying I used
Blender in the last one, but I didn't.
So, I I thought like, "Oh, let me let me
use Blender in this one, and it'll be
like um it'll be like a funny bit." So,
I spent like six hours trying to get
this scene to look good. And it like
I like can't get it to look uh look
super good. So, I don't know if I'm
going to be
I don't know if I'm going to be using
Blender. I think I I think it'd be a
funny bit. Um, however, it might not be
worth it cuz I think I still have the
clip. I think it's I I can bring it up
on stream cuz I wanted to ray trace it
cuz I think ray tracing looks good.
I'm like genuinely autistic.
Where is it? Yeah, here it is.
So, this 4 second clip took like
>> There it is. the time, the date, the
address down to try and hide it, but
nope. There it is. The time, the date,
the address.
>> It It looks good. It looks good. Um I
just don't know if I want to commit
to using Blender. There's a reason I
don't use Blender because it takes
[__] forever to render [__]
especially with my [__] shitty CPU.
It's terrible. It's terrible. It would
be a funny I would laugh at it. This is
a funny bit for me to use Blender in the
video. So, I don't know if we'll keep
going with it. I don't know. I think
it's funny. I'm like [__] though.
All right, I'm going to rate it out.
Bye. Bye, guys. W bit. W blender bit. W
blender bit.